what about if someone is feeling shy
they don't have a lot of social
confidence how can someone overcome that
how can they develop more
so
i think that uh we talk often about how
courage is a muscle and it's not the
answer that a lot of people want to get
but i think progressive exposure therapy
is it really is the way and so again in
the course we start very easy if you're
shy
you're probably biting your tongue often
not saying that you think and you're
probably mistaking that for i don't have
anything to say nothing comes to mind
the truth is the filter in your head is
so high
that nothing breaks through that as
being worthy of being said and so when
we're talking to shy people what we
often tell them to do is with
say that you're in a situation with a
taxi driver or uh someone else who's
working for you a waiter a cashier say
one extra sentence right so the normal
thing is that'll be 592. you give them
your thing but something is in your head
there's a magazine cover there the
weather is hot uh they have a nice
earring or something say one extra thing
and what we're trying to teach them to
do is to lower that filter of what would
be acceptable to say to someone now
there are people that have the reverse
problem where they blabber on and on and
on and we need to teach them to be a bit
more selective but when you're shy i
think that's oftentimes the biggest
problem is that
you
think that the things that you have to
say are such crap that you communicate
that with every fiber of your being and
so once you're saying them then we have
to teach okay
say with your chest say it like you mean
it don't don't trail off at the end of
sentences if you're in a group
conversation
do not let someone cut you off until you
hit a period so if you're mid
conversation with someone and you're
finishing your thought and they jump in
you have to get to the end of it like
now
and then they can take over so it's not
about being a conversational bully it's
about learning to
take up conversational space in a way
that is assertive uh so that's
that's a very common thing that we see
with shy people is that they're
reluctant to do that but just a handful
of
of models like those goes a long way and
also like they didn't cut me off a
second time they realized that i wasn't
going to just disappear and you know
they feel very happy about it
what about the tailing off at the end of
sentences thing that's definitely
something that i notice people do if
they're uncomfortable in a social
situation or a little bit shy how can
people overcome that
what the general rule is you have to
finish it with the same decibel level
that you started it with you've you've
got to find a way and
the way that we teach people is like
look these are new habits when you're
learning them they might not feel like
you it's going to feel uncomfortable
you're going gonna go this charisma
thing isn't for me
so just focus on one thing per day our
videos are in part entertainment they've
got five six things if you try to do
that all you are going to live in your
head we want you to be in the
conversation reacting listening but also
i do want you thinking of one thing that
you're going to do differently that day
and so what we do in the course is we
structure it differently so you have one
thing for each day but if you're a shy
person and you're out there the thing
that you might think of for today is
if i'm in a group setting this evening
make sure that i finish any sentence
before i yield the floor and that's it
and then you can do whatever you want
you could be awkward with your body
language you could make crappy eye
contact you could say dumb things but
you just focus on that and over time
you're stacking these habits on top of
each other such that when you get five
six seven eight of these together
you really do have a much more powerful
personality
talk to me about the tension between
needing to learn a skill in
communication
and needing to be sufficiently in the
conversation to be able to flow through
things because you have this system one
system two dynamic going on here right
we need to be very deliberate system two
i'm thinking about it oh [ __ ] i'm
thinking about it i'm thinking about it
so much that i realize i haven't moved
my body for the last three minutes i've
been constantly thinking about finishing
my sentences at the same [ __ ] decibel
level because of that charlie guy yeah
yeah so and this this is attention and i
have
the ways that i hear people say to
relieve it just be yourself i find art
do not actually lead to growth they
might lead to evolution over time as
things go back but if you want to
deliberately grow i think you have to
deal with this tension
the way that we've done it is just by
having one thing that you're focusing on
per day and it would be one small thing
and sometimes it's literally just a
thing that occurs at the beginning of an
interaction like i'm gonna say my answer
to where are you from like the one that
i practiced and built as opposed to the
one that is reflexive
and so that's how we do it so that there
definitely is some time where i'm taking
you out of the flow of conversation and
i recognize that but i do i have not
found a better way to learn a skill i
think it requires deliberate i don't
know it's system one or two it requires
that deliberate removing yourself from
the flow of how things have always been
a little bit for a period of time
there's an awesome awesome story about
tiger woods when he was
early in his career and he realized that
he had some um
how would you say perversions in his
swing he had some
efficiency
versions yeah yeah he got some
promotions elsewhere as well um he had
some perversions in his swing that was
causing him to be less accurate and less
consistent than he needed to be and the
decision was look
if you want to be the best in the world
we need to rebuild your swing
from scratch
and this meant that he had to take a
bunch of steps back he'd stop being
system one he could have gone on being
the perfectly adequate type version of
tiger woods for the rest of his career
without having to do this so he
purposefully had to get worse before he
could get better because he was going to
have to relearn all of the different
things and i kind of feel like there's
an analogy to draw here between this and
purposeful conversationalizing
100 and i don't know how tiger went
about that and maybe maybe there is a
better way that i've yet to discover but
it's the way that i did it because i was
getting overwhelmed when i was trying to
do everything i remember just being like
okay and you stand like this and you do
this and all of a sudden i could be in
his social interaction and not have been
there literally at all i was just
totally in the realm of thinking
planning scheming in my head and so that
didn't work which is why we went back to
the let's take one element of this swing
at a time let's start with just doing
what we do with a different grip let's
now let's worry about the hips now and
and that was how
over time i was able to still be an
interaction still be in my head a little
bit but
building towards what wound up becoming
a very different way
after months and years of doing this of
of being generally yeah and i'm guessing
that reps repetitions of this oh gosh
yeah and
you nailed it yeah i'm forgetting the
most basic stuff and i appreciate you
bringing it up it truly is just reps uh
the nice thing is that
you know how there's beginner gains in
the gym because nobody focuses on this
stuff it comes so quickly this is not
like
it's easier than learning an instrument
it's easier than than putting on muscle
mass
and it's because
it's it's like if you lived in a world
where no one worked out how quickly
could you go to the gym before your body
made you exceptional like it wouldn't
take very long and that's the world that
we live in with regards to charisma is
nobody's working on it so all you have
to do is is this very small amount
before people are going to start to
notice that you're in an elite tier
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you